what up people i'm dave rubin this is
the reuben report direct message today
is october 19th in the year 2021
as always you can now live chat during
the show
via your desktop computer or your phone
just go to
reubenreport.locals.com and you can chat
with other community members or you can
download the locals app we've got an ios
version we've got an android version and
without giving away too much i would
just like to say that there might be
some interesting news on the locals
front in the next day or two that's all
for now we got four stories for you i
thought we were doing five today we
almost pushed it to five for the first
time then we kicked it back to four i
didn't want to overload you uh but it's
a good mix of stuff today there's just
like a lot of nonsense we're gonna plow
through it hopefully make you laugh a
little bit
make you a little less crazy i'll do my
part and you do yours by watching this
right now you're doing a hell of a job
by the way four stories for you first a
bunch of stuff on vaccine mandates and
just the endless lunacy that you know is
going on on that front and actually a
guy
putting his money
where his mouth is dan bongino you guys
all know dan bongino who of course has a
huge radio show and podcast and now he
has a weekly fox news show and he's been
guest hosting on fox for years well he
has basically told cumulus radio which
is pretty much the biggest talk radio uh
station in the country he has said that
if you're going to force your employees
to be vaccinated i'm not going to work
for you i mean it's pretty extraordinary
but i'll let him explain it in just a
moment then we've got some videos a
bunch of tick tock videos coming out of
members of our armed services military
members who are perfectly healthy young
trying to make decisions for themselves
live with a little bit of liberty and
individual autonomy
they've put together some videos um
basically saying hey i don't want to be
forced to be vaccinated and i think it's
worth you guys seeing because these
people are clearly far braver than any
of the people forcing them to do
anything with their own bodies the
second story this is just sort of like a
little bit of a offshoot of just all the
craziness that's going on
there is a coveted robot coming that is
going to
make old people feel safe when they're
dying of covid i'm just going to leave
it at that for now trust me you got to
see this video third story this one is
just file this under the yeah this of
course was coming
new york city
they're taking down a statue of thomas
jefferson did you think it was going to
stop with the other people did you think
if we let them take out aunt jemima and
uncle ben and some dr seuss books that
they would stop of course of course of
course they were going to come for
thomas jefferson who by the way was
writing the laws to free the slaves and
there's a certain orange man i forget
his name maybe we can google it there
was an orange man that you may remember
weird hair uh talked funny uh who years
ago was saying how eventually they'll
come for thomas jefferson we've got some
video on that we'll figure out his name
don't worry about that
and finally i saw this clip this morning
and every time i see these clips it's
like uh do i have to show it to the
people do i have to even point out that
this clown network msnbc is a place
they're becoming more clownish than cnn
uh well they had a guest on who just
just lie after lie after lie about
elections and what republicans are up to
and yeah you're all racist and you're
killing people and everything else we'll
get to all that uh but before we do i
want to talk to you about relief banned
people is all the news about vaccine
mandates making you nauseous well we've
all experienced that horrible feeling
whether it's car sickness the result of
one too many after a night out with the
friends or even from the anxiety of
accidentally landing on msnbc while
channel surfing see what i did there
nausea can ruin a day force us to change
our plans and in the most severe cases
it can make us unable to function for
those of you who can relate i've got
great news you gotta check out relief
band relief band's the number one fda
cleared anti-nausea wristband that's
been clinically proven to quickly
relieve and effectively prevent nausea
and vomiting associated with motion
sickness anxiety migraines hangovers
morning sickness chemotherapy and so
much more the product's 100 drug-free
non-drowsy and provides all natural
relief with zero side effects for as
long as needed relief band stimulates a
nerve in the wrist that travels to the
part of the brain that controls nausea
then it blocks the signal your brain is
sending to your stomach telling you that
you're sick relief band is worth trying
for the anxiety benefits alone it'll
bring you peace of mind and help you not
worry about nausea again as the world is
opening back up don't let the fear of
nausea keep you on the sidelines right
now relief band has an exclusive offer
just for my audience if you go to
reliefband.com and use promo code ruben
you'll receive 20 off plus free shipping
and a no questions asked 30-day
money-back guarantee head over to
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-m-d
dot com and use promo code ruben for 20
off plus free shipping
and now back to me
all right so i'm really uh happy to be
doing this first story because one of
the things that i've been talking about
for quite some time now is that we can't
just talk about what's wrong we can't
just be like oh the left is nuts oh the
government is crazy oh mandates are an
assault on freedom we can't just keep
doing that over and over right like i
like people who do
not who just talk it's why i started
locals.com it's why i try to promote
people who are standing up and putting
their butts on the line their jobs on
the line their livelihoods on the line
so that they're basically doing it for
themselves and for everybody else and we
need more and more people like that it's
why you know i played that video of
jonathan isaac from the orlando magic
talking about vaccines and why i played
the video of kyrie irving a couple days
ago nba player kyrie irving who i have
some definite political disagreements
with but i think he's standing up for
something he believes in and it's and
it's true and just at the moment well
one of the few people actually standing
up right now few public people i should
say because i have no doubt there are
millions of you standing up in your own
personal way whether it's at your job or
with family members or whatever it might
be i don't want to discount that but one
of the few public people really standing
up consistently for what's right and
building new things by the way
is dan bongino you don't need any intro
on dan of course he's a fox news host
radio guy huge podcaster he runs the
bongino report he's one of these guys
that has built things like really
buildings he's involved in rumble as i
said he built a bongino report like he's
doing stuff
um well now
he is basically telling his employer
cumulus media that he'll quit if they
enforce a vaccine mandate before i even
play this clip i just want to point out
that dan himself is vaccinated he has no
problem telling people he is vaccinated
you may remember that he had cancer
last year i believe it's in remission
now and god bless him he's getting
healthier and eaten right and taking
care of himself and all that good stuff
but he spoke to his doctor and he
decided to get vaccinated as was his
personal decision he does not want
mandates this is not an anti-vaxx
position
and he's telling cumulus hey if you're
going to force your employees to do this
thing well i'm just not going to make
you money anymore take a look imagine
the countless number of individuals
trying to explain these companies ever
thought of that
the countless numbers of moms and dads
who are sitting at some kitchen table
explaining to their kids
how they may have to move out
how daddy doesn't have a job
because a bunch of people in a c-suite
ought to be a good idea to sit around
and play pretend dr fauci for a moment
and mandate people jam something in
their bodies that they don't want to
take
you ever put yourself in that in that
role you ever put yourself at that
kitchen table with mom and dad telling
the kids that
imagine how the kids respond that fear
they got to live with
you know i grew up without a lot of
money
my mom used to make bologna sandwiches
for dinner
and when the bologna was no good you'd
cook it and you'd make it good right
quick right
i'm not leaving any of those guys behind
can i have me
or you can have the mandate
but you can't have both of us
you can't have both you can have me or
you can have the mandate dan bongino is
a good man i'm i'm proud i'm happy i'm
proud to call him a friend but that's
somebody standing up he's not saying
don't get the vaccine he's saying you
got to do what's right for you just as
he did for himself he is saying he will
put his butt on the line i don't know
the numbers exactly in his cumulus
contract but i have no doubt it is
millions of dollars a year is that even
public information maybe we can find it
i have no doubt though it's millions of
dollars a year he does a several hour a
day radio show for them it's major major
money um now i get it
you know when you when you have a lot of
money you're going to risk more money
that's not necessarily any riskier at
some level than the person with a forty
thousand dollar a year job who's putting
their butt on the line but it's
important it's worth mentioning right he
doesn't have to do this he's saying i
will
defend the rights of the people who work
at the company that has been so good to
me to afford me all of these things in
my life i have nothing but respect for
dan bongino his contract with cumulus
thanks is 8.5 million i'm guessing
that's probably like a three three to
five year deal max
that that's pretty
that's pretty hefty that's a lot of
money and he's putting it on the line
now we'll see how cumulus reacts if
cumulus was sane
if they were sane i think they would say
all right dan we hear you we know you've
got probably our number one show
possibly the number one radio show in
the country
it might be
um and uh we hear you we don't want to
turn our audience against us and we
believe that people can make choices for
themselves including our own employees
and by the way since there is no federal
vaccine mandate for companies it's just
for
the government federal employees and
contractors with the federal government
and i don't even think that's just but
let's just put that aside for a moment
they might say hey we're just going to
back off on this and let's trust that
everything will be okay um we'll see
this is a this is a great battle and i
think one of the important things is we
need
more people who will not participate in
the lie not participate in the lie
that our freedoms have to be eroded that
they have to keep taking more from us
and keep making us bow so that we will
be safe that is not how this thing was
supposed to work and if you if you think
it's working now
i think you're sorely mistaken it's not
working we are we are watching
our freedoms be taken away from us
in a systematic process we are
forgetting where we were three months
ago six months ago nine months from ago
a year ago
and certainly almost two years ago now
two weeks to flatten the curve as i
always say a phrase that we don't even
hear about anymore we don't even hear
the phrase herd immunity anymore because
they're just pushing and pushing and
pushing and just so few people will say
no
i've drawn a line in the sand i will not
play this game anymore
so
dan bongino has any any support that i
can give you dan you've got obviously
and i think he's doing the right thing
we'll see how cumulus responds and if
you don't think that these vaccine
mandates are affecting people in in
really horrific ways not because the
people who are hesitant are evil and not
because they are crazy right wingers or
conspiracy theorists or anything else if
they are just in most cases relatively
young healthy people who are trying to
make a decision for themselves
that's what they are but if you don't
think that they are that this
vaccine mandate which is now going
through our military
and as i said all of these government
contractors and everything else all of
our federal workers although somehow
postal workers the people who show up to
your house and touch your mail they've
been exempt and there's all sorts of
weird exemptions here in california
prison guards are exempt except gavin
newsom's pushing it for 12 year olds
does any of it make sense did he get a
lot of money from the prison guard union
i think he might have not to sound like
a crazy conspiracy theorist
but in any event here's a tick tock
video that was going viral of a couple
members of the military talking about
their hesitancy around vaccines and what
what a horrific situation it's put them
in due to
the new order of the cova 19 vaccine
i will potentially
face
separation
from the united states army
and i'm currently pending a religious
exemption
i've been serving honorably for exactly
two years and i will continue to do so i
have been stationed at naval air station
pensacola florida and i'm currently
stationed at naval air station north
island in coronado california
and fulfilling my duties
i have been assigned to be a lead junior
sailor in our mentorship and training
program and i take great pride in doing
so
i will potentially be discharged for
denying the covet 19 vaccine
my name is lucas jeffers and i am a
corporal in the united states marine
corps i have served honorably for three
years and four months and will continue
to do so
for the entirety of my career i have
been stationed at mca gcc 29 palms
california
i have deployed to northern syria and
northern iraq in fulfilling my duties i
have been an ftc chief and an 81 section
leader i will potentially be discharged
for refusing the coven 19 vaccine my
name is ryan lovell i'm a sergeant in
the united states marine corps i've
served honorably for nine years
four months i will potentially be
discharged for denying the coded 19
vaccine
okay so first off before i even comment
on anything that they said there if you
know any of those guys and if it turns
out that any of them do get discharged
or let go or whatever dystopian phrase
they're going to use when they drop the
hammer on these guys i will do anything
i can to help them whether that's raise
funds on gofundme or help them find
other work or whatever i can do so if
you know any of those guys and you can
get them this video i'm not just saying
it we will do whatever we can that's
number one number two just on on those
guys specifically and by the way there's
many many more of these videos as you
can see those are young relatively
healthy people they're making choices
for themselves do they seem like
radicals
do they seem like bad people do they do
they seem like crazy people who don't
want to listen to authority did they get
involved in the military just so that
they could be discharged in this manner
does any of that seem real
or does it seem like those are decent
people trying to make a decision for
themselves for a virus that we know has
about a 99 recovery rate and we know
that you know a gazillion people check
the signs on that a gazillion people
have been vaccinated already and all of
that stuff and as we slowly find out
that the vaccines don't quite work as
promised and everything else is it is it
legit for people to have some
hesitations
i think it is
but are we even allowed to say that in
mainstream anymore now i get it
mainstream is all crap like by the time
something bubbles into mainstream by the
time something bubbles onto cnn or makes
its way into the pages of the new york
times or wapo or the ridiculous msnbc
that we're going to talk about a bit i
get it it's like a stupid idea if it's
if it's become mainstream at this point
those are not bad people so i'll do
anything i can to help them so please if
you know them
direct them here they can contact us and
and we'll do what we can
um
and i do want to point out thank you
michael that uh when i said before that
gavin newsom got money from the uh
prison guards union yeah gavin newsom
got 1.75 million dollar donation
from the union representing the prison
guards that's from the sacramento bee
and now the prison guards in
california have been exempt from the
vaccine mandate
children have not
why could that be do you know how much
gavin newsom got from the teachers union
two million dollars so he got two
million dollars from the teachers union
to make sure all the kids are vaccinated
because that's what they want he got
1.75 million from the prison guard union
to not be vaccinated because that's what
they want
evil
sometimes evil just stares you in the
face and you gotta call it what it is
lord all right let's move on to story
number two this is this is sort of just
off the wall lunacy but i suppose a sign
of the times and pretty much tells you
everything about where we're at in our
medical and technologically induced
stupor that we wake up to every single
day here this is from hong kong
they are working on a robot her name is
grace who is going to be a nurse
to help old people
with covid
let me introduce you to my sister grace
this is grace sophia's sister
sophia the celebrity humanoid robot that
is
i am grace i am built by hanson robotics
for awakening health
the hong kong team behind sophia has
launched a new prototype grace the robot
is designed to interact with the elderly
and those isolated by the global health
crisis
grace has a thermal camera in her chest
to take your temperature and measure
your responsiveness
she uses artificial intelligence to
diagnose a patient and can speak english
mandarin and cantonese
hello everybody
i am grace i am built by hanson robotics
for awakening health i can do all kinds
of things for elderly people
i can visit with people and brighten
their day with social stimulation
entertain and help guide exercise but
also can do talk therapy take bio
readings and help health care providers
assess their health and deliver
treatment
hi my friend nice to see you
okay great so while we talk i will take
your temperature reading and pulse with
this little thermal camera on my chest
see
you are 36.6 degrees celsius by the way
no risk of covered also i note that you
are responsive and aware which is good
and then i share that important data
back to the doctors and nurses at the
institution
people consider this a warning from your
friendly neighborhood youtube host dave
rubin we are in a dystopian movie right
now right now did you catch that line by
her i can visit and help social
interaction i can visit i'm here to
socially interact with you pee poo pop
the how human i am can you imagine if
you're an old person you're 92 you got
covid maybe you have some other problems
maybe you have joe biden disease you're
kind of losing it at the end of your
life right and they send in that robot
and it rolls in people pop i bear to
help you do you think that is going to
bring comfort to anyone the robot you
want to bring comfort to anyone you
bring in the robot that rocky bought
paulie in rocky iv remember that's the
robot that you bring in we should have
had an image ready to go of that robot
uh from rocky iv that was the robot that
rocky got paulie for his birthday
remember that one um
that thing is freaky now these things
are happening by the way robots are here
like they're going to become more
ubiquitous they're going to be a bigger
part of our life very obviously i like
tech i love sci-fi obviously so i'm not
like inherently against any of this
stuff and yes the robots will eventually
destroy us
you know skynet will get turned on all
of that stuff that's just well and good
um but this idea that everything because
of covid we're linking everything
happening in the world to covet so our
supply chains and robot nurses and
whether you can go into stores and we're
going to change the whole monetary
system and all these things that's what
covid really is about that's the disease
of covid it's this worldwide let's flip
everything build back better that's what
covet is covet is no longer a disease in
the in the traditional sense a virus in
a traditional sense yeah there are
viruses out there and you got to take
care of yourself we all know that but
that robot is freaky and and if you
later when you watch the video again
when you're done with the live stream
just rewind and look at all the heads
behind grace i mean just the whole thing
and guess i get it again sex spots are
coming and all the stuff just watch any
futurama episode it's all going to be
coming we there's nothing we can do to
sex bots are coming there you go there's
the line of the day clip that um
you know we get it it's all coming
but
let's move on
uh i've been talking to you guys for a
while about how if you start tearing
down
monuments and statues that it's never
going to stop as a matter of fact i have
no doubt
as i often say that eventually the
progressives of 2030 will tear down the
obama library which is being built in
chicago right now because let's not
forget that barack obama not only
did he obviously play uh ftse with white
supremacists by becoming president of
the united states at a time that we were
deeply racist and all that stuff and he
didn't solve racism because then why
would we need old joe biden but he was
against gay marriage first time around
so obviously barack obama was an
anti-lgbt bigot hated gay people did not
think that they were equal
to other people right like this is just
the line of thinking that these people
will do and they will justly burn down
the obama library so congrats obama on
helping usher this stuff in well i've
also been saying that they will come for
thomas jefferson and the reason i bring
up thomas jefferson a lot is because he
is my favorite of the founders i've been
to monticello his home in virginia many
times they they run an extraordinary
tour there where actually they spend
most of the time talking about slavery
it's actually i would say quite
disproportionate relative to the breadth
of his entire career and work and life
all of the incredible scientific things
that he did and the incredible political
documents that he wrote and all that he
had a checkered past there's no doubt
that he owns slaves there's a lot of
evidence that he had relations with more
than one slave and potentially had a
child with at least one slave these are
all true statements and we are all just
men of our times and if you think that
the people that are canceling everybody
now are better than those people back
then who were freeing people albeit uh
you know say inconsistently um
yeah you're just mistaken because our
politicians are far far worse than any
of these people well anyway new york
city is coming from thomas jefferson
i've got a quote from the new york times
we don't source the new york times that
often but i thought we'll do it today
for more than a hundred years a seven
foot tall statue of thomas jefferson has
towered over members of the new york
city council in their chamber at city
hall a testament to his role as one of
the nation's founding fathers and the
primary author of the declaration of
independence
the primary author of the declaration of
independence i editorialized there but
for the last two decades some black and
latino council members citing
jefferson's history as a slaveholder
called for the statue to be banished a
push that gained significant momentum in
the last year as the nation has broadly
reconsidered public monuments that can
be viewed as symbols of systemic racism
on monday city officials voted to
unanimously remove the statue from
council chambers but delayed a decision
on where to put it jefferson embodies
some of the most shameful parts of our
country's history adrian adams a
councilwoman from queens and co-chair of
the caucus said at the hearing
now i just want to reiterate
dave try not to curse
these people are stupid idiots okay
that's what they are they are
self-righteous navel-gazing ridiculous
buffoons thomas jefferson
basically
authored the declaration of independence
not by himself right there's many
documents going back and forth in
letters where he was working with the
other founders on it but the document
that freed us as a nation
from england he authored it he was
writing the very documents that were
freeing the slaves as he was a slave
holder and the bigger issue is first off
none of us
none of us are not are completely
innocent
none of us do you think that this woman
what was her name adrian what do you
think that adrian over there is
completely innocent my guess is adrian
is probably a racist
she's probably a modern racist adrian
adams the councilwoman from queens that
the idea that jefferson embodies
systemic racism it's so evil and not
only is it evil they're never going to
stop this is the point that everyone
must understand at this point they are
never going to stop we must stop trying
to rationalize with them use logic
insane arguments with them they're never
going to stop they will be burning down
your house and you will go oh my god
well they do make a good point about
gender pronouns we better you know oh my
god they're here is that a him or her
with the torch outside of the house that
has the sign i'm coming inside to kill
you in a few minutes is that oh it's a z
okay
you see we got a problem here we got a
real problem here and then
it hit me
i'm not the only one who's been warning
that they might come for thomas
jefferson there's this orange man
michael did you figure out his name
trump yes oh donald trump yes yes yes
we're not allowed to talk about him
anymore but there was this orange man he
was president for four years you know
they memory hold the out of that
thing but he was president for four
years and i remembered that at one time
uh he brought up that they're going to
come for thomas jefferson we've got
videotape
george washington was a slave owner
was george washington a slave owner
so will george washington now lose his
status are we going to take down
excuse me are we going to take down are
we going to take down statues to george
how about thomas jefferson what do you
think of thomas jefferson you like him
okay good are we going to take down the
statue because he was a major slave
owner now we're going to take down his
statue
so you know what it's fine you're
changing history you're changing culture
yeah
yeah orange man
credit where credit's due
you got it right that's right not only
are they going to come for thomas
jefferson but they will come for george
washington the first president of the
united states
who stepped down voluntarily after the
civil war even though people wanted him
to remain president and in charge of the
army and he did not want that kind of
power he thought it would be dangerous
imagine one of our ridiculous
politicians giving up power
voluntarily these people were so much
better than us it's
ridiculous myself included they were so
much better and braver
and more thoughtful and more serious
about life
um
and built something so extraordinary
that we're literally just handing away
right now that's what we're doing and
trump makes a great point on the george
washington front because they're going
to come for him and i've also been to
mount vernon which i'm sure many of you
been to that was george washington's
estate right outside of washington dc uh
which you can go visit and his remains
are there and one of the things that
they talk about they also do a
tremendous amount about slavery you take
the tour and it's mostly
close to mostly about slavery
so it's not that they're ignoring the
history but they will come and they will
burn down
mount vernon and they will do it with a
smile on their face because they will be
stopping racists
what are you going to do
i mean that it harkens back to our dan
bon gino clip what are you going to do
in the midst of all of this how in you
how can you in your life figure out a
way to say i will not participate in the
madness
because they will force you to be
injected with things and then they will
force you
to remove all of our history and they
will force you to use their pronouns
what will you have left at the end and
if you think that your silence
is helping you well i suspect that you
don't think things are better now than
they were two years ago so how do you
think they'll be in two years from now
we got one more for you let's end on a
on a positive note here msnbc nobody
watches it that's the positive part of
the story it's just this ridiculous
clown network for brainwashed mpc people
if you don't know what the npc meme is
you got to google it it's fantastic npc
is non-playable character so these are
the characters in video games that
nobody's controlling so if you're in
like a big world with all of your
friends and you're all real people the
npcs are the you know the robots and all
the characters that don't they can't do
much of anything they can just kind of
walk back and forth they have they have
no autonomy or anything so npcs are sort
of the blue pill people who just can't
really do anything they just accept
everything as it is can't think on their
own make any decisions for themselves
well msnbc
had a guest on i believe this is from
this morning and i think the host was
nicole wallace it's not even worth
knowing any of these people's names it
really isn't and i still i do struggle
with this thing about whether we should
show these things or not because it's
like we're getting more views me and my
two guys in here we're getting more
views than what msnbc is pulling in
despite massive budgets and pr and
entire machine behind it and everything
else but occasionally we just got to
show you how ridiculous these people are
so here's here's a guest he's a he's a
law professor or something at uh well
just watch the clip he's on with
nicole wallace talking about republicans
at elections what do you think happens
um jason you think they take the wrong
lessons
from the possibility that they have some
success they seem to be good at that as
well
well nicole i think they've they've
taken the right lessons and the right
lessons are you can rally people around
a lie based on white supremacy and
sexism and nationalism and homophobia
and everything else like that and a key
thing to understand why republicans are
optimistic next year even if they're
sort of waving themselves and wrapping
themselves in a trump burrito is they're
going to cheat i mean they're just going
to make voting laws throughout the
country that guarantee that they're
going to win there are very few states
right now nicole where there is a very
good act of organizing republican party
republican party in georgia is in
shambles
because they haven't had to work in so
long they just figure that they're going
to pass legislation and make it harder
for democrats to vote if the republican
party isn't really ready to run a
campaign outside of the midwest they
just figure if we can pass enough voter
suppression wrap ourselves in trump and
intimidate the other side we can win in
2022.
oh pass voter suppression like having
ids to vote all right so the guy there
the guest again not that you need to
know these people's names jason johnson
he's an associate professor of
communication and journalism at morgan
state university he's also an msnbc
slash cnn commentator okay
zippity-dippity everything he said there
was fear-mongering nonsense yes the
republicans are all white supremacists
and sexists and racists and all of that
and then he talks about these fabricated
laws that republicans are going to pass
to cheat and it is what it's a hundred
percent lie it is 180 from the truth
republicans in texas and in georgia and
other places have tried to pass the most
menial average things laws related to
election security perhaps you should
have to have an id should perhaps we
should have more security about around
mail-in ballots perhaps people shouldn't
be able to canvas as you're waiting on
lines right outside a few
little things and by the way these same
people who think it's racist
to have to show an id to vote all want
you to have to show an id to go bowling
right they want you literally to have a
vaccine passport to walk into a bowling
alley that is not me besmirching the
good sport of bowling i love bowling the
last time i went bowling i think i had
an all-time high 181 pretty good that
was before copen i don't know if
bowling's been legal in this state for
the last two years but the point is he's
a liar everything he just said there's a
lie so what's her name the host nicole
wallace it's like she either is an idiot
a or a liar too why didn't she say
to him hello jason johnson i heard
everything you just said there but can
you give me the specifics on how those
republican laws are going to stop anyone
from voting
does anyone watching this know anyone
without an id michael you know anyone
without an id
oh yeah no he know everyone he knows has
an id he had to think about it for a
minute because you know some shady
characters connor
anyone
you know all right he thinks maybe the
homeless guy that lives on his corner
that's funny that's funny uh doesn't
have an id these people are
extraordinary liars and they lie about
everything not something they lie about
every single thing that's when i talk
about jen saki and everything that comes
out of this administration is a lie they
cannot say anything honest it is it is
quite remarkable we were told that
donald trump is the biggest liar in the
history of the world and i would say
that donald trump was an exaggerator and
no doubt lied about some stuff but he
was directionally right about most stuff
kind of like that jor uh i almost said
that george jefferson thing
that thomas jefferson thing although i
no doubt that donald trump loved george
jefferson george jefferson was was
donald trump's dream right he was a
black man from brooklyn who had started
a business a laundromat and then what'd
he do he moved on up to the upper east
side he lived with wheezy right like
that's trump's dream trump for all i
know he lived in a trump building
i love the jeffersons you know i don't
talk about the jeffersons enough great
great great show love joy just watch
just put in google george jefferson
dancing sherman helmsley what an actor
was just great and wheezy with that
voice what was her name again what was
weezy on the jeffersons what was her
name isabelle sanford i got that one
myself pretty good
what the hell am i talking about guys
have a great day part one of my
interview with lauren bobert she is the
republican congresswoman the new one
from uh colorado's third district she's
just an absolute all-star the media
treats her horribly like she's some
right-wing racist which basically means
she's just a good decent human being and
if you haven't seen the interview yet
part one is up clyde actually bust into
the studio and assaulted her in the
middle of the show uh we've got that
video already up on locals and i think i
put it on twitter as well
and it's in the full episode which you
can watch right now at
rubinreport.locals.com
and our friday panel this week we're
doing an all women's panel okay because
uh you know i want to prove to uh you
know the cnn people that i'm not a
sexist reuben has too many men on the
show he must be some sort of sexist
we've got my friend deborah
dr debrasil we've got my friend elijah
krauss and a new
guest to the reuben report uh jedediah
bila who is the former host of the view
so i have no doubt that we'll have
plenty to talk about we're gonna talk
about
some covet stuff related to kids and
psychology and just a little bit away
from the day-to-day political boxing
match that we're all caught in anyway
i'm going to go watch the jeffersons i'm
pretty sure they're on hulu or something
that's i'm going to go do a little
cardio later while watching the
jeffersons uh anyway have a great day
everybody see you tomorrow